the pandemic is hitting Latinos in the
u.s. particularly hard Latinos account
for more than 27 percent of deaths in
coronavirus hotspots but only about 18
percent of the population and as Adriana
Diaz shows us the virus is also taking a
financial toll on the community in
Chicago's Latino neighborhood of Pilsen
people who are out of work and out of
options
line up hours early at this Food Pantry
at this point demand has outgrown our
supply family physician dr. Evelyn
Figueroa opened the pantry two years ago
but since the pandemic demand is up by
almost 50% just as we've been standing
here I've seen people join the line this
tells us that people are really they're
really on the fringe how are you
managing it's a lot of word in mouth and
hustle forty-nine percent of Latino
households have seen job losses or pay
cuts in this pandemic Latinos who still
have a job face increased exposure to
the virus because only 16 percent can
work from home the fewest of any ethnic
group or race people like this cleaning
lady who we agreed not to name because
she's undocumented she said I wouldn't
be able to take it if I brought this
virus home to my children especially
because my son has asthma it's a smart
thing cool so she's decided to stay at
home but now she and her husband who
works construction have no income and
because they're undocumented they don't
qualify for unemployment food stamps or
the federal stimulus first generation
American Jose Gonzalez whose parents are
from Mexico is also worried about
getting his daughter sick he works as a
cook at a hotel housing Kovac patients
we don't have the benefit of I should
just stay home to you know not carry on
that such a high risk and I feel like
that's every Latino at this point
essential workers and many different
domains they are disproportionately made
up of Latinos and other people of color
so they don't get the luxury of self
isolating and staying at home and
flattening their own curve they have to
go out in order to get paid
for CBS this morning Adriana Diaz
Chicago